hi
welcome to another episode of cold
fusion where i cover anything in science
technology business or history
most of us take our eyesight for granted
but there are many people out there who
can't view all that the world has to
offer not because they simply need
glasses but because of a genetic disease
this is something that's been unfixable
until now
in this episode we'll take a look at how
an emerging technology called crispr has
allowed people to see again increasing
their quality of life and has brought
them much joy
[Music]
so today we'll take a quick look at what
crispr is how it works and the latest
experimental research restoring site to
those who need it
let's take a look
[Music]
so firstly crispr is an acronym it
stands for clustered regularly
interspaced short palindromic repeats
alright so that sounds like a lot but
the name really isn't important for
today what is important is the fact that
crispr is a biological tool that can be
used to edit genes
think of it like a biological pair of
scissors that can cut dna but also has a
component that can insert dna
it's super low cost and can be done by
researchers or even someone in their
backyard garage gene editing can now be
done in ways that used to be really
difficult or if not impossible before
so this crispr tool can quickly and
efficiently tweak almost any gene in any
plant or animal
researchers already have used it to fix
genetic diseases in animals to combat
viruses and to sterilize malaria-causing
mosquitoes they've also been used to
prepare pig organs for human transplants
or to create glowing animals including
dogs cats and rabbits
the crispr tool was first described in
2012 and since then there's been a
massive realization of how powerful this
tool is crispr has so much power that
there have been calls to be careful on
how humans use it but more on that at
the end of the episode
so how does it work exactly
so crispr is a way of finding a specific
bit of dna inside a cell when that
specific part of the dna is found the
next step is usually to alter that piece
of dna
so sometimes it can be cut but other
times it can be used to turn specific
genes on or off
in the crispr system a special enzyme is
used by scientists as a pair of
molecular scissors
these tiny scissors use an artificial
guide made from rna a kind of messenger
of instructions on where exactly to cut
the dna
the guide searches along the dna
sequence until it finds its target think
of it a bit like a google search
once the right part of the dna sequence
is found the enzyme cuts the dna
the dna then tries to repair itself by
searching around for the nearest bits of
dna to grab
the scientists have already introduced a
new dna sequence along with the guide so
when the dna is searching for something
to grab it picks up the dna that the
scientists have introduced and it
stitches it into itself
a microscope and a tiny needle can
inject both the biological scissors and
the new pieces of dna at once that's
oversimplified but that's essentially
how it works
so let's move on to the experiment
along the way of innovation some
scientists have come up with the idea of
using crispr as a gene therapy
the headline case of today's episode
involves injecting crispr therapy
straight into the eyeballs of the
visually impaired the aim was to
directly correct genetic defects
as crazy as it sounds the results was
vastly improved vision from most of the
volunteers even allowing some to see
color for the first time
so two studies one published in april of
2021 by the university of pennsylvania
school of medicine and a second study by
harvard medical school in september of
2021 have been recent drastic
breakthroughs in gene editing in humans
in one of the studies a legally blind
patient regained their vision for over a
year after getting a single injection of
the crispr gene editing treatment
in both of the studies the treatments
were to reverse a specific mutation
caused by a genetic eye disease that
goes by the name of liber congenital
amyourosis or lca
lca causes progressive blindness early
in life and patients are usually legally
blind by adulthood
so how does the treatment work
well the genetic disease lca prevents
cells from producing a particular
protein
cep290
and this protein is crucial for the eyes
photoreceptor cells the crispr treatment
sneaks some rna into those cells and
triggers the production of cep290
essentially reversing the mutation for
months at a time
in the first study the researchers saw
continual improvement in the patient's
eyesight and the restored eyesight
actually peaked for two full months
after the injection and lasted for over
15 months
as the study authors explained this
result was a great sign for gene
therapies at large
[Music]
in the second study multiple
participants all of whom had lca were
extremely happy that their vision was
improved from the gene editing treatment
the treatment of course is experimental
and still far from curing lca but the
changes that some have experienced were
significant enough to have a meaningful
impact on their daily lives
let's take a look at some of the results
some of these anecdotes just warmed my
heart vision says he's starting to see
again after taking part in a
revolutionary gene editing trial to try
and restore patients eyesight we first
introduced you to michael in may he
spoke to us about being the second
participant in the world in a
groundbreaking medical trial designed to
try and restore vision to visually
impaired patients the study involves the
revolutionary gene editing technique
called crispr for michael who was born
with cerebral palsy this is life
changing he shared videos with us of him
picking up and drinking from a glass
something he couldn't do easily just
last year my visual field was so
constricted that i my muscles would
tense up and i would tense up when i was
trying not to spill it i can grab it a
little bit easier because my eyes relax
my brain dr eric pierce one of the trial
investigators with mass eye and ear
tells us in a statement we're thrilled
to see early signs of evidence that gene
editing is working and functioning
inside the body this has never been done
before and is a major step for science
still striving to be my very best and to
make sure
that
changes in my vision because progress
isn't always linear don't cause
alterations in attitude or work ethic
the next step is for michael to continue
testing at mass eye and air to track
progress in vision and the safety of
this trial the hope is for this crispr
treatment to become more widespread in
the years to come in mineola long island
dana archan fox 5 news that is
incredible
one patient karlene knight says that she
can see colors far more vividly and feel
safer walking around at work
quote
i was bumping into cubicles and really
scaring people that were sitting at them
it's nice i don't scare people and i
don't have as many bruises on my body
it's kind of fun to see
she even dyed her hair green to
celebrate her newfound ability to see
her favorite colour
her vision is brighter clearer and
instead of having to reach and fumble
around for objects she can simply now
just look for them when talking about
the experience of dropping a fork on the
floor she states quote i just leaned
down to pick it up and i didn't even
know where it was and just saw it on the
floor it's really cool
it's such a simple thing for us but for
someone to begin to be able to see again
must just mean the world to them
volunteer in the experiment michael
calburo has begun to see colour for the
first time in years
he first noticed it a month after the
procedure when a red car drove past but
the most dramatic event occurred on the
dance floor of his cousin's wedding
quote i could see the dj strobe lights
change color and identify them to my
cousins who were dancing with me that
was a very very fun joyous moment
he's also gained more peripheral vision
and can finally watch sunsets again
he recalls the first time he saw one
after the treatment he was coming home
from a meal with a friend when he saw
pink in the sky
quote
yeah you see the sunset
that's the sunset and we both smiled at
each other it was a great moment
he finishes off by saying i'm just
incredibly honoured and privileged to be
a part of this and very very excited to
literally hopefully see what comes in
the future
[Music]
as for the scientists involved in this
breakthrough they're very optimistic
harvard medical school ophthalmologist
eric pierce who's helping run the
experiment told npr quote we are
thrilled about this we're thrilled to
see early signs of efficacy because that
means gene editing is working this is
the first time we're having evidence
that gene editing is functioning inside
somebody and it's improving in this case
their visual function
dr mark pennissey professor of
ophthalmology at the kci institute at
the oregon health and science university
states quote it's really amazing
technology and very powerful
[Music]
so we should talk about the shortcomings
firstly the procedure didn't work for
all the patients the harvard scientists
theorized that either the dose was too
low for their vision or that the
unresponding patients were too damaged
by their genetic disease
it's also important to note that none of
the patients have regained absolutely
normal vision but the improvements are
already life-changing with no
significant side effects observed the
team cautioned that more patients need
to be treated and followed for a long
time to confirm safety
interestingly the results have been so
promising that researchers have been
given the go-ahead to move on to the
next group of patients
the researchers have begun to administer
a higher dose which could work better
and they eventually plan to start
treating children who have the best
chance of benefiting
they're also optimistic that the vision
of the patients could improve further
with time as mark pennissey states
quote when you improve the vision of the
retina sometimes there's a lag for the
brain to be able to recognize and use
that vision it takes some time to learn
how to use that improved vision
so crispr is already showing promise for
treating anything from blood disorders
kidney diseases and even as a cancer
treatment
the results from this study could open
the door to using the same approach to
treat other diseases where doctors can't
take the cells out of the body this
includes brain disorders and muscle
diseases
and recently to top it off scientists
just recently performed the first pick
to human kidney transplant the patient
was a brain dead individual on life
support they used crispr to turn off the
genes that would usually cause the
kidneys to be rejected by the human body
when you put an organ
from a pig into a human is it going to
do what it's supposed to do in this case
the pig's kidney needed to rid the human
body of waste and remarkably it did
no evidence of this vigorous early
rejection
and the second thing the kidney
functioned well
likely because this was no ordinary pig
researchers had knocked out one of its
genes that triggers the human body to
reject pig organs with family consent
the kidney was attached outside the body
of a woman who had suffered brain death
researchers then watched as it started
producing urine the
significance of
moving you know this into a human i
think can't be understated the hope is
to allow for organ transplants to be
more readily available for people who
need them
okay so some words of caution
what we've seen is an amazing use of
this technology but we have to think
about it carefully when it comes to
genetic modification there's still a lot
that we don't know
what if there's some unforeseen changes
that we don't know about yet because the
technology is just too new what if
crispr technology can cause off-target
mutations that is to edit a gene that
they're not supposed to
there is still plenty of scientific work
remaining to completely understand
crispr but we do have to do our best to
make sure it's as safe as possible once
a mutation is in the general human gene
pool it really can't be stopped
we should also be careful of less
positive uses you all probably remember
what happened in 2018 when a chinese
scientist hijian kui reported that he
had created the first human babies with
crispr gene edits a pair of twins
resistant to hiv
the announcement stunned the scientific
world and the director of national
institutes of health francis collins
said that the experiment was quote
profoundly disturbing and tramples on
ethical norms
so don't get me wrong i really don't
want to take away from the amazing
progress that's been made it can clearly
change lives and make people's lives
better in a very positive way
i mean just the fact that it's making
people's eyes better and letting them be
able to see again is just amazing
all i'm saying is i hope we just proceed
with caution with crispr so what do you
guys think are you fairly chilled out
about this technology or do you see it
as going a bit too far
or maybe you're somewhere in the middle
it'll be cool to get a discussion going
though if you do want to discuss in more
detail the best place to do that would
be the cold fusion discord
so that just about wraps it up i'd also
like to say that the podcast has started
up again so if you want to find the
podcast versions of these episodes you
can find it on spotify and some other
platforms
links will be below alright so that's
about it from me
my name is dagogo and you've been
watching cold fusion feel free to
subscribe if you want to see more so
i'll see you again soon for the next
episode
cheers guys
have a good one
[Music]
[Music]
uh
[Music]